this week I introduced we are in my
first page
[Music]
right now I'm watching the react
tutorial from lynda.com they want to
achieve the moment when each sub page
whether it's for websites applications
or design will render appropriately just
only when clicked and this portfolio
will be single page discussion which is
better the one that which is outstanding
or the one at which we are setting I use
both of them but the best desk is the
desk from what you stand up very often
and go go out in order to stretch out
your muscles
[Music]
this week I also announced another
coffee and cold meat app in Malaga and
already for a local campers decided to
take part of it for our local market
people to come fruit farm members still
it's a step farther because more people
I don't take part on the last time this
week I was learning a lot about the
react and I have just touched the basics
of react for the lovers from our
programming and the react for a long
time it's like nothing what I did
despite the fact that small step I
really appreciated that that I managed
to do it this week each step comes
especially if you learn something from
scratch you start it you did it you use
the first event of react code in your
app in your website and everything works
and everything is fine so now you can do
the step for yourself making small steps
but in the direction of progress it's
always was it a basement this is how the
page looks right now since the last week
I changed the pattern here behind the
hook the colors I created my own pattern
in this section of repositories and I
also added the pages that are loading
here dynamically so
I chose few applications one website
right now and one example from design I
note these portfolio sub pages using
reacts I use routing to as you see the
link changes dynamically look here we
have applications website and design I
tried the first time to load the
subpages this way using react it wasn't
easy at first I found a great article
that helped me a lot and I also asked
for some advice more experienced
developers this week I was also working
on styling get up at Moore's this is how
it looks on smaller screens it's fully
responsive one more thing I wanna share
and that I will provide link to in the
video description below is the mock-up
tool the online backup tool you can
customize the final results so what size
of the photo we get and and the other
thing is online and you don't need to
use Photoshop or any other tool every
now next week so the next week next week
I'm going to continue the portfolio sign
I'm going to test this Paroli
next week I also get a few meetings and
in one of them I will be your inviting
and discussing my account of the
previous project later it will be time
to come back to frequent challenges
[Music]